Speaker 1: All right. Some extraordinarily
explosive new allegations that have surfaced
in the last 24 hours regarding the former
guy. That guy, the orange menace, Mango,
Mussolini, whatever. Right. You know, the guy I'm
talking about. The first is that failed. Former
President Donald Trump asked his lawyer to lie
to the government for him. And this is just an
unbelievable story. Bess Levin from Vanity Fair
reporting surprise Trump, a pathological liar,
reportedly asked his lawyer to lie to the
government about his classified document,
Cash. The ex-president wanted his lawyer to say
he'd returned everything in February, which was
obviously not the case. This relates directly
to the other Trump lawyer, Christina Bobb,
who eventually did make the claim that everything
was returned. It was a lie. And as I told you on,
I believe, Monday, she has now lawyered up.
Maga making attorneys get attorneys best,
Levin writes in quoting The Washington Post.
The Washington Post reports that in early 22,
the ex-president asked Alex Cannon, an attorney
who had worked for both the Trump Organization
and the Trump campaign, to tell the National
Archives and Records Administration that all
materials requested by the agency had been turned
over, despite the fact that Trump was still in
possession of thousands more government documents.
Now, another thing we learned yesterday is Trump
personally packed a bunch of those documents, but
we will get to that. But the point is, Trump knew
the documents hadn't been returned because he had
them okay. According to the Post, Cannon, who had,
quote, facilitated the January transfer of 15
boxes of presidential records from Mar a Lago
to the National Archives. After Archives officials
agitated for more than a year to get all original
presidential records did not feel comfortable
making such a claim. In other words, it was a lie.
He reportedly told people he didn't know if all
the requested material had been returned and
quote, Other Trump advisers also encouraged Cannon
not to make such a definitive statement. Did
Cannon hesitate because he was aware of the fact
Trump had a long history of lying about everything
all the time? Who is to say? Cannon didn't respond
to the Post's request for a comment. So think
about how absurd this story has gotten. We still
don't really know the motive for why Donald Trump
kept these top secret and other documents. We
don't know where the ones that are still missing
to this day went. That's another story. There's
a dozen layers to this. We have the picture.
Of the folders for top secret and otherwise
restricted documents which were empty when the FBI
found them. Obviously, Donald Trump didn't take
empty folders, meaning the documents are somewhere
and we don't know where are they? At Bedminster.
Another one of Donald Trump's clubs, golf clubs,
whatever you want to call them. We don't know
why. But the point is, not only do we not know
the whereabouts of some of those documents, we
still don't really know the motive for taking them
because the stories we've been told don't make
any sense. Trump wanted it for his library. He
never talks about his library. He doesn't care
about his library. Trump wanted them to read.
Trump doesn't read. Trump wanted them in order to
write his memoirs. Trump doesn't write. There's no
plausible, innocent reason why he would want
those. And then you get into the not so innocent
reasons which include selling them or whatever
the case may be. The other aspect to this is
that, remember, the Justice Department
thought the situation was serious enough
to conduct a search warrant at Mar a Lago. Now,
this isn't a criticism of that decision. This
is just a reminder that if the Justice
Department felt this was that serious.
There may have been reason they believed something
was about to happen with these documents. If the
impetus for the search warrant was less about
we're imminently charging Trump, but more about we
have reason to believe he's about to do something
with these documents, then that would be a whole
other area of exploration. But then there's.
Trump wanted his lawyer to lie. Trump knew the
documents hadn't been returned, and he instructed
his lawyer to lie. His lawyer didn't do it.
Alex Cannon. Eventually, Christina Bobb, another
lawyer, was willing to make that claim on paper,
and she has now obtained a lawyer and is willing
to cooperate with the Department of Justice. And
she herself is facing possible legal trouble. And
then the next part of this is something else we
learned yesterday. Trump personally packed
a stash of documents to take to his house.